oh we're gonna play the predator yes
hello my god
now look at him
hey guys i'm back at it again this time
behind the screen
today we have a very special video we
will be playing predator hunting grounds
remember the classic 1987 film of the
predator starring me honey
just take a look at that sweet chocolate
it's so powerful
i can't wait to play this
look at that face
he's terrified it brings me back to the
old days when we got the mission in
central america and [__] is about to go
down
all right here we go let the chopper
he kinda looks like me but it's not me
who are you
tell me
[Music]
we find more babies
get them
i lied
didn't work
i'm
back over here
come
on what the [__] is the button no
no
what the [__]
kill it come on everybody no
no
come on guys
but that wasn't a good start
you tried again
oh we're gonna place the predator yes
oh my god
that was so good
it's so cool
i feel amazing look at me jam
like a [__] frog
oh
[Applause]
my god this is the best day ever
if he bleeds
we can kill it
[Music]
just been erased
slicing the icing
are you in the race for breakfast
i'm very hungry
stick around
your [__] quiet body come back to me
boy
[Music]
[Applause]
oh yes
i'm the party pooper